conforman la otra cara de la cumbre de
las américas la de los que no han sido
invitados los líderes de cuba venezuela
y nicaragua junto a los otros miembros
del grupo alba rechazaron desde la
habana las exclusiones de la cumbre
definidas por eeuu anfitrión este 2022
la práctica de kuyt web web y confirme
el interés de eeuu por controlar el
sistema interamericano para utilizarlo
en función de objetivos hegemónicos e
imponer un poder fiscalizador de la
democracia pero eeuu se ha mantenido
firme hasta el momento sólo invitará a
la cumbre a los países que consideran
democráticos algo que ha dejado
inmediatamente fuera a venezuela y
nicaragua y en duda a cuba que ha dicho
que no asistirá aunque finalmente sea
invitada situación con la que otros
países como méxico o bolivia han
expresado su solidaridad
rechazamos enérgicamente la exclusión de
pueblos hermanos
la cumbre de las américas y se hicieron
mi decisión de no asistir a dicho
encuentro mientras no se invita a todos
los gobiernos de los países de américa y
en condiciones de igualdad jerárquica y
de participación en una clara división
entre la américa socialista y los
estados más proclives al progresismo
capitalista hagan lo que hagan en
washington la voz de venezuela
la voz de cuba y la voz de nicaragua
llegará a los ángeles no obstante eeuu
podría cambiar de opinión ya que todavía
no ha anunciado los invitados oficiales
a la cumbre que se celebrará del 6 al 10
de junio en los ángeles